というふうな考え方で
そういう話になっちゃったんですね
そこで あの    20年ぐらい前かな
もっと前ぐらいかな ヨーロッパで書いたテキストなんかは
まあやっぱり徹底的に我っていうのはあるんだと
そこでまあヒンドゥー教でも仏教でも同じことを言ってるんだと
真我のことというふうなことを言い始めたったんですね
結局 これは我でないと言っちゃったら
いえ 違うもの我ですよと言うんです
それは我でないと証拠を出しちゃったら
いえ そうではなくて違うもの我ですよと
もう永遠に逃げて逃げて
我論はずっと世の中でも生き続くんですね
いわゆる証拠ないものは我でありますという結論に立っているんだけど
みんな気づいてない 証拠ないものは我であるというならば
それは永遠に生きてられるんです
証拠を出しちゃったら
それは我に争だから だから仏教から見ればすごい馬鹿馬鹿らしいんです
なんで証拠ないものは証拠ないんだからあると言うんですかね
それ屁理屈でしょ 証拠ないものは証拠ないんだから存在すると
実体 だから実体というものにこそ堂々と証拠があってほしいんですね
実体だから 煮ても焼いてももう変化しないものだから
一番証拠あってほしいものには全く証拠ないことだから
だからそういうものは放っておきなさいと
我々は体験する世界で
どこに自我意識が生まれてくるかと
そこで心清らかにすることをやってみようと
そこで見たところで 私が見ているという感じが生まれてくる
聞いたところで 私は聞いてるんだという感じが生まれてくる
ああ これは聞くことを見ることを感じることを味わうこと
考えることによって 私が私がという概念が生まれてくるんだと
そこで私が誰ですか？という実体がないんではないかと
それなのに我は 私は私という幻を守ろうとしてるんではないかと
それを永遠にしてあげようと思ってるんではないかと
でもそんなことはただの無意味な努力であると
じゃあそういう欲を捨てましょうと
捨ててもう限りない安らぎを味わおうというのが仏教の話なんですね
だから我という実体論が出てきちゃうと
人間がものすごく束縛されちゃって苦しくなるんです
たとえ阿弥陀様が救ってくれるとくれるんだと思っても
まあ一部は落ち着き もう楽でいいという感じがあるんだけど
やっぱりそれによってすごく束縛されちゃうんです
息苦しくなっちゃうんです
神様が見守っていようと思っちゃったら
もうもう手も足も出なくなっちゃうんです
で 守っているならばね
うまくいけばいいのに
それ物事はうまくいかない
どんなお祈りしたって不幸になる時は不幸になっちゃうし
不満はその通りであるし
たとえ神様に完全に守られているよと信じ込んでいる人も
神様は全然存在しないと思っている人も
生きることは同じく苦しいんです
仕事をしなきゃ収入は入ってこないし
真面目に頑張らなきゃもう何一つうまくいかないんですね
ですから 生きる苦しみはみんなに同じですよと
なので神様に守られているんだと思ったらさらに納得いかなくなっちゃうんです
守られているのに なんで？というふうなこと出てくるんですね
みんなただそういう質問しないだけ
例えばイランの方々はもう徹底的に原理主義でイスラム教なんです
ものすごい恐ろしいほど原理主義なんです
最近問題あったでしょ
この食料の援助をしている人々追い出されて
裁判で 女の人を雇ったんだ
その女の人がヴェールを被っていなかったんだと
アフガニスタンの人々苦しんでるんだから
もうせっかく食料配ったり
なんとかみんな見てあげてるんだから
そこでお手伝い頼んだ人々がヴェール被っていなかったんだからって
なんかそれはおかしいんだと
でもその人々にとってはこの宗教っていうのは
自分の言うかは世界中みんな法律で守ってあげなきゃいけない
本人はどうでもいいんです
だからヴェールを被ってなかった女の人は間違ってるんじゃなくて
フランス人が間違ってるんですね
その屁理屈さえ考えないんですね
もしイスラム教を信じているならば
イスラム教の聖書で女の人はもう顔も目も手も全部被せておきなさいと言っているならば
それは守るのはその人の義務でしょうに
イスラム教の信者さんの義務でしょうに
私たちの義務じゃないんです
例えばイスラム教の人は断食しなくちゃいけないんですね
1年に 1ヶ月間 そこでイスラムの友達が私の家に来たところで
私は何のことなくご飯作ってあげたんだと
それでもしその人がご飯食べちゃったら
私はもしイランとかね
そういう それからサウジアラビアとかそういう国に住んでいたならば
私はもう年刑務所なんです
食べた人じゃないんです
そういうおかしな生き方は全部
どんなイスラムの国でも誰もそれに反対しない
怖いんだから でもおかしいことはおかしいんです
別に私はイスラム教に反対ではなくて
イスラム教で断食しなさいと言っているならば
信者さんが自分の責任で義務で断食を守らなくちゃいけないんです
例えば私が豚肉作ってあげても
その人はそれを断らなくちゃいけないんです
私たちの宗教では豚肉食べてはいけないんだと
ですから あなたの家ではご飯食べませんと
申し訳ないんだと 友達
あなたは友達関係なくなってもしょうがない
神様のことは守りますよと言うならば正しいんであって
私の宗教では何食べてもいいんだから
私はその通りにやっているだけのことで
そこでもう裁かれますから
もう法律に だからおかしいというとおかしいんですけど
そういうのが出てくるんで
そこで言いたかったのはイランのことなんですけど
もう徹底的に神様を信じていて
それで地震があって もう何百人も人々が死んじゃったんですね
もうもうこのもうすぐ最近でしたけど
そこで死んじゃったのはものすごいこの貧しい人々なんですね
見るたびにものすごくかわいそうで
もうそれからまたそれ冬でしょうに
食べ物はないわ 着るものはないわ
全部もうちょっとしたこの土で作った建物だから
全部もう平らになっちゃっているところはないわ
その上もう夜になってくるともう零下十度ぐらい冷えちゃって冷えてしまう
もうどうしても地震が起きたければ
なんで夏にやってくれないんですかとかね
なんで家が倒れたっても
もう新しい家が建てられるぐらいの金持ちの人々にやってくれないんですかとか
でもその国ではもう徹底的に神様というものを信じてるんですね
だから私が言うのは そういうことを信じていたっても
生きること自体は苦しみであって
不安なんですね 信じていない他の人々にも同じことなんですね
ですから 日本にも地震があるんです
イスラム教でなくても
神様を信じていてもいなくても
もうしょうがない もう神戸の地震もやっぱりちゃんと計算して冬に起きたんだから
夏だったらすごい楽なのに
あの援助活動も復興 復興活動もなんだかんだよね
昼は長いし どこでも寝られるし
一番きつい冬に限って
もう今も原発地震あるんだけど
もうそろそろ春だからもう何も大きな地震は起こらないでしょう
これ 11月  12月  1月だったらちょっと危ない
ですから まあそこは事実だからね
それを見た方が 仏教から見ればそれは合理的できちんとした考え方
ですね ですから そういう概念があると
さらに生きることは苦しいだけ
みんなでもそれ救われてるではないか
例えば自分の旦那さんが癌になっちゃったと
それで悲しくて泣いたりする
そこでまあ神様の意思ですから
まあいいんじゃないかと思ったら納得いくんだと
納得いくところでしょうかね
あれはごまかしだけなんですね
神戸の場合 僕にその質問もうどっとぶつかられたんだからね
そこでいろんな人々はやっぱりもう自分の親戚を死んじゃったところで
阿弥陀様にも迎えていただけましたから
別に悲しまなくてもと
やっと阿弥陀信仰あったんだから救われたんですよ
だから僕はいちいち反対するのは
まあどうですかと 現にその人は救われたんではないかと言われたところはこともあったんだけど
でもあれごまかしでしょ？自分の親が死んじゃって
おじいちゃんが死んじゃって
もう 20秒以内で 4人
3人  5人ぐらい自分のみんな死んじゃう
自分一人になっちゃって
阿弥陀様に連れて行かれたんだから
まあいいんじゃないかと
で それならなんで自分も連れて行かなかったんですか？と
なんで僕はいないんですか？だからごまかしてもう落ち着くっていうことは僕は認めないんだよ
元気になれと しっかりしろと
親が死んじゃって それはすごい悲しいと
なんでそれ認めないんですかね
もうご飯も喉を通らないんだと
夜も寝られないんだと
それ事実でしょうに もう不安で不安でしょうがないんだと
それで仏教はもう世の中はそういうものだと
今も過去もこれからもそういう不安定な状態にあるんだと
あんた今神経質になったって別に解決方法も何もないんだ
だから放っておけ 落ち着けと
あなたも今すぐ死ぬかもしれませんよ
そういう事実を見たら
そんなもんかとと納得して理解するんですね
自然というのはもうどうすることもできないでしょうしと
だからできることをやればいいと
家がもう壊れたならば
まあお金あるならば 小さいくても新しい家作りなさいと
親戚はみんな死んじゃったならば
残ったもので頑張りなさいと
いちいち泣くなと という風な具体的な教えは仏教なんですけど
そこはみんな人気ないと言うんだからしょうがないんですね
そういう風に言われると
何か超能力でもね してなんとか
そんなものありっこはないしね
超能力でもなんとかしてくれた経験ケースはないんだから
だから本当に仏教立場から僕みたいな人間だったら腹が立って何も言わないぐらいの性格なんですけど
お釈迦様は だからお釈迦様にすごく慈悲がありましたと
人間がそれぐらいわがままでいい加減でも
苦しみは嫌で嫌ですけど
苦しみだけ消してくれるなということを言ってるんだから
それなのに親切に教えたんだから
もう本当にもう僕はもうお釈迦様にはすごい慈悲があったなと思いますよ
僕だったらもう絶対 そこまでわがままだったら勝手にしろ
だからこの仏教っていうのは
すごくこの自分だけの悟りをなんと考えるんだと文句言われるのはそこら辺から出てくるものだと思います
人としては 腹が立つんですよ
やり方に 自分が苦しんでるのに教えたらもうそれに反対するんです
それだったらどうしようもないでしょ
じゃあどうぞ勝手にご自由に頑張ってくださいと言って
自分の心の解脱のために努力するしかもう答えが出てこないんですね
それに大乗仏教文化はね
まあ自分の個人が自分が悟るために修行するのは
そういうけしからん教えは小乗仏教だと人を救ってあげるのは我々の大乗仏教でいて一人も救ってくれない
その代わりに阿弥陀様を信仰しなさい
大日如来信仰しなさい
大目公を唱えなさいと
嘘を本当にいいところなんですね
ですから お釈迦様は慈悲とヴィパッサナー瞑想を両方両立してやりなさいと
たとえ悟った人にしたっても
やっぱり死ぬまでは慈悲のエネルギーは必要なんですね
人々はやっぱりかわいそうだと
みんないくらわがまま言っても
まあちょっと教えてあげようと
ここでも教えて せっかく自分が生きているんだから
ということで それは正しい慈悲で
何も見返りはなし 見返りはなしではなくて
見返りは要りませんということで
というふうなことになっているんです
話は全然関係ないところに行きましたけど
僕はその話に行ったのは
この見の話で 世の中っていうのはそういう風に何か実体的なものがあるんだと思い込み思い込んでいる
全ての思惟はその思い込みに基づいて出来上がっている
それは思い込みによって見があるんだから
美味しいものはあれ 美味しいという欲が生まれてくる
ですから 見がある心に
もう心が欲の心だと 不善な心だと決めているんです
天国があると思っちゃったら
そこへ行きたくなるんです
真我があると思ったら真我を体験したくなっちゃうんです
それだから見がある心
だから見がある心で行動すると罪の方が多いんです
それで見がない心でも欲があるんです
例えば私にしても 見はないんだけど
美味しくないものよりは美味しいものは食べたいんですね
食べる時は 何か音楽を聴く希望するならば
全然気に入らない気持ち悪い音楽よりは
自分の気に入る気持ちいい音楽を聴きたいと
その場合 別に見があるわけじゃないんですね
服を着る場合は 汚い汚れているボロ服を着るよりは
この衣はボロボロなんですけど
正直なところはきれいな新しい衣を着たいんですね
着るならば それが欲といえば欲なんですね
でもその場合は見がないんです
それは具体的なんですから
美味しくないものを食べるよりは
美味しいものを食べるのが楽しい
それだけのことで ですから
見がある欲の心もありまして
見がない欲の心もあります
冬だったらまあまあどんどん
前はそうではなかったんだけど
僕はもう外へ出るのも嫌で
部屋の中で暖房つけちゃったりして
前は冬は楽しくて楽しくてできるだけ外にいたんだけど
どんどん  もう年取ってくるとなかなか怠けが出てきて
やっぱりもう暖房つけちゃって
それでするんですね 外いろいろ用事があるんです
出たいなとかね でも寒いんだから嫌です
そこはやっぱり楽をしたいということだから
欲の心なんですね でもそこに見があるという風には言えないんですね
邪見に基づいてやっているわけじゃなくて
ごく普通の欲なんです
ですから 欲は2種類に考えて
見がある欲と見がない欲と
それはどんな人間にもあります
例えば どんな徹底的な邪見がある人にあってあろうとも
やっぱり美味しいものを食べたいとかねということ
これでは別に見がない時なんですね
そこで悟る場合は 悟る過程に過程によって
この本当にすべては無常だと分かったら見が消えてしまっちゃうんです
見が消えてしまっちゃったんだけど
それでもやっぱり美味しいものを食べたいということは残っちゃうんですね
仲良くしたいとか 子供の面倒見なくちゃとか
それも欲なんですね それは残っちゃう
ですから 悟りに段階が出てできているんですね
無常は体験したんだから
もう悟った全ての煩悩消えたぞということにならないんです
本当は基本的なものは消えちゃいますけど
まあそれでもやっぱりもう家族を守りたいとかね
子供のことを大事にしたいとか
今んとこなんとかそういうのを残ったりして
それでもうさらに修行しちゃうと
そういうことに夢中になったっても
まあまた意味がないという
そこをまた判断して徐々に離れていっちゃうんですね
ですから 悟るには残念ながら段階があります
禅宗ではどんな文句を言ったっても
まあそれはしょうがない
禅宗ではまあ何とんごうとかなんとかと言って
いきなり一発で全部悟るさとか言うだけで
悟った人はどんな心を持ってますか？とかね
悟りってどういうものかという全く説明ない
ただ お釈迦様は悟りということを教えたということだけ知ってるんですね
哲学ではなくて実践論だよと
それだけを知ってるんです
そこで じゃあ実践だから実践しようと
何を実践しようとわかってないんですね
そこら辺で禅宗禅宗ももうガタガタ状態なんですね
悟りということをよく聞いたことがあって
本当の仏教教えは悟りの教えですよと知ってるんだけど
それは何ですかとわかってない
だからまた同じく大した知らないもののためにみんな頑張ってるんですね
一生懸命座禅組んでいる
だからこのいくらこの禅宗の素晴らしい文献はありますけどね
本当にもうすごい最高なもう文献いっぱいあるんだけど
読んでも面白いし もう心に響くこといっぱいあるんだけど
だからといって 人の役に立つかなということがまた問題なんですね
方法論を持ってないんだから
ですから やっぱりこういうことを悟りであって
こういうことは心の汚れであって
こういう方法でこの汚れが消えちゃいますよ
消えてこういう風な状態になりますよというふうな
きちんとしたシステムは必要になっちゃうんですね
お釈迦様はそういうふうなものを作りましたけど
この仏教は宗派に分けていっちゃうと
まあ抜けた抜けて抜けて抜けて難しいことは置いておくんだから
で 抜け殻だけ残っちゃうんですね
そこでまあ私たちはこの浄土真宗仏教と頑張ってるのは
この抜け殻にまたこの命をなんとか入れてあげようと
ということなんですけどね
復活しようと でもそれも無駄な努力かもしれません
世の中は無常だから復活にならないかもしれませんし
じゃあ で いろいろ欲がありますが
一応すべての欲の心は八つに分けていて
次の四つになりましたけど
八つになるのはこの行
サンカーラがあるかないかということだけで
サンカーラっていうのはこの心のエネルギーで
自分でこの 進んでやる場合もあって
もうちょっと考えてやるというふうな
ちょっと説明しにくい区別なんです
それはこの結果とってもあんまりただ区別してるだけのアビダルマでも
そのサンカーラアサンカーラの区別はそんなに考えてないんです
ちょっとした心の働きなんですね
だから性格から見てもすぐ行動する人もいて
もうのんびり行動にする人もいるんですね
考える時でもサッと考えてしまう人もいて
まあ順番でゆっくりと考えてあ
分かったぞという人もいるんですね
その区別だけなんです
それはこのアビダルマの心理学ではそれほど意味がないんです
意味がないんだけど もうとことんその区別もしているんです
例えばサンカーラがあってした悪いこととサンカーラがなくした悪いことの結果は差がありますかというと
差がないんです それほど差がない
差があるのは他のところで差が出てきますけど
なんでその区別が出てきたかというと
私の推測なんですけど
この悟りのところの分析に心理学的な分析になっちゃうと性格分析というテキストがありまして
で そちらにはこのキッパディンニャ
ダンダディンニャという 2つの専門用語が出てくるんですね
すぐ悟れる人と まあかなり時間かけたところで悟れる人
ひらめきという言葉で
すぐひらめく人と もう時間かけたところでひらめくという
この性格の差なんですね
どっちが便利かというと
すぐひらめく方が便利なんですね
大体後で知恵が出るということはごく一般的なんですね
その瞬間に知恵が出てこないんですね
人々はな あとはああすればよかったと後で思い出しちゃうんですね
あの時はこういう風に答えればよかったのにと
後で思い出しても もう本当はもうその場合遅いんですけどね
その場で現場でサッと思い浮かんだらいいんですけど
でもそれはどうしようもないんです
性格だから 後で気付く人も
すぐさまがで気付く人の 2種類は性格としてある
修行では大事なポイントなんですね
人がすぐ悟る場合もあります
それはものすごい鋭い人で
すぐひらめくと 長い間
もう何年も何年もコツコツと努力することによって
じわじわとひらめいてくる人もいます
ですから それは理解しておけば安全だと
ですから 修行の目的でそういう区別があるんです
ちょっと二人で修行に入ったところで
一人が 1週間でなんとかになりましたならば
もう一人の人はやっぱり私は失格だと
ダメやと と落ち込んでしまっちゃうんですね
もし指導様があなたはもうダメですよと
そういうふうに人はダメだというふうに決めつけることは仏教はない
人はもう排除はしません
破門という概念は仏教でないんです
あんた破門ですよ 追い出しますよ
お坊さんの社会からは
もし戒律なんか破ったら
それも追い出すんじゃなくて
追い出せ 自分で失格になる
お坊さんがあなたは失格ですよと決めない
そういうふうにシステムは
失格になっても あなたには修行は失格です
悟りは失格ですよとは言わない
お坊さんとして戒律破ったならばもう帰れませと
帰って在家でいて 在家として頑張ればいいんです
それで悟る可能性はまたあるんですよ
ですから 破門ということはない
それはあくまでも教育上ではありますけど
いくら破門ではなくても
何て言いますか もう停止しちゃうとかね
権利を停止するとかね
お寺から追い出すとか
いろいろ罰はあります
それはお坊さんたちだけのソサイエティの社会の活動なんですね
言うことを全然聞かないとかね
わがままだったら あなたは他のところに行きなさいと
あるいはサンガからあなたの権利は全部停止と
そういうふうなことをして
後でそれはやり直せばもうわかりましたと
これから頑張りますという言葉でまた入れてあげたと
また無茶なことをしちゃったら
またまあ まあそれがごく普通の人々を育てる方法だけで
教理的には破門はないんです
ですから 人は排除しません
ですから 指導する人場合でも
人に教える場合でも わかる人もわからない人でも言います
いますが やはり気長くしてわかるまでまあ教えるしかないんです
同じ教えでももう 100回でも 200回でも言って言って理解するまで気長く人のことを見ることは必要なんですね
だから自分でも短期で 1週間頑張ったところで何もならなかったんだから
まあいいやとやめましたとっていうのは良くないんですね
やっぱり根気よくというんですか
根気強く もう結果が出るまで努力してほしいんですね
仏教は精進努力っていうのは仏教の道徳の中でもものすごい大事にしているもので
そういうことだから この心理学の中で
この結果としてそれほど意味がないにも関わらず
この行 行ある行ないという心の 2つの分析が出てくる
行というのは まあ画期的なエネルギーだと理解すればいいんですね
ですから 自分たちの場合でも
やっぱり大体自分の勉強でもありますから
自分の心はちょっと鈍くてすぐひらめかないんだと
まあだからといって別に落ち込む必要はないんですし
私はそんなものだから
まあこすこすと頑張ればいいんだと
ですから 年下の人々は自分を乗り越えてどんどんどんどん行ったとしても
それを気にする必要はないんです
今日初めてこちらに参加した人でも
ものすごく言っただけで仏教のことを理解してたのか
要するにそういうのは気にする必要もないんです
そういう個人個人の性格は違いますから
そういうことで じゃあ
それからこの欲といえばいろいろ欲があります
タッハディッティマナですね
高慢 慢がありますね 自分という自害意識
それ高慢も欲の心の一つなんですね
自分が偉いとか 自分が等しいとか
自分が偉くないとか 卑しいとか思ったりする場合
自分が自分を他人と比べて測る時慢と呼ぶんですね
慢というのは測るという動詞なんです
比べる 比べるというのは測ってみるということ
どちらの方が偉いかと
で  9種類のマナがありましてね
で 相乗満と同等満と何とか満なんです
ちょっと後からその専門用語出てくると思いますけどね
自分がすごく偉いと 自分が人と等しいと
他よりは卑しいと思うこと
それから偉い人より偉いと思うことと
偉い人と等しいと その偉い人よりは自分が衰えていると思う
この相乗満の 3つと 同じ人よりは自分が偉いと
同じ人と同じ 同じ人よりはちょっとしくと思う
この同等満の 3つと で
自分が低いんだけど 低い人よりはもっと偉いんだと
低い人々と同じだ 低い人々よりも低いと思うっちゃ
そちらに 3つと 9つ出てくるんですね
測る方法 ただそれだけでマナという言葉で終わりますけどね
ヨーロッパ心理学ではそれコンプレックスなんですね
そこはすごくむちゃくちゃなんですね
今日本で使っているこのマザーコンプレックスやらいろいろありますけど
そういうふうに考えちゃうと
もう分からなくてもめちゃくちゃやっちゃうんです
じゃあマザーコンプレックス悪いですか？ないんですか？と
それどうやってなくしますか？と
僕はそんなことはもう考えない方がいいと思いますけどね
で 母の影響を受けるのは当たり前であって
どんな母に影響されてないと言っちゃっても
人間 僕は最近思い出したことなんですけど
子供っていうのは我々はいくら年取って
いくら両親に逆らっても大嫌いですよとか
見たくもないんで 家出で出たっきりで
死ぬまで両親死ぬまで戻ったことがないと言っても
その人は一人の人間で生きてるんだから
母両親に設計された生き方の中で生きてるんですね
だからもう忘れることはないんです
小さい時はこういう風に食べなさい
こういう風に喋りなさい
こういう風に生きなさい
こういう風に人に接しなさいと
基本的な生き方ももう教えられちゃったんだから
それで自分というものを思っただけのことで
自分が独立して頑張ると思ったって
やっぱり教えられた通りにやってるんだから
もう抜けられないんです
そこはコンプレックス概念で扱うのはもう意味がないんです
そこで親が家を出たんだからといって母親が泣くのは全く意味がないんです
親と喧嘩して逆らって出た人に限って親の言うことを守るんです
いつもそういう現象みたい
社会見たらそういうものなんですね
早く家出する人に限ってコンプレックスすごく持ってる
コンプレックスじゃないんだけどね
そういう風なものですからね
仏教ではそういう概念じゃなくて
マナと自分と他人を比べてみると
そこは普遍的であって
何のコンプレックスでもなくて
みんな持っていることで
親が子供を育てるときで
いつでも比べて比べて教えちゃうと
それをずっと引きずっていっちゃうんですね
もし親が人に比べるんじゃなくて
あなたはあなたで判断して行動しなさいと
これはどう見たっても悪いでしょうと
隣の子はやってないんだからあなたもやるなんていうのはなくて
これは悪いでしょうと
だから悪いことをやめろ
やめろと言ったら そこでマナがないんですね
測ること 比べること 隣の子供と同じくあんたも勉強しなさいと言っちゃったら
その人は一生誰かライバルがなければ立派に行動しないんですね
会社に入ったっても もっとしっかり頑張ってる人がいなかったら自分が頑張れなくなっちゃうんです
見張っておかないと だから社会でどこを見ても見張り役はあるでしょうに
上司という人がいて 部下の仕事を見張っている
どこを見ても監視役 見張り役あるんだから
あれは強烈なコンプレックスなんですね
なんで見張っておく 例えば物を盗んじゃうでしょ
盗めないのに ありとあらゆる見張りをしておくんですね
法律とか決まりとか そこなくなったらもうすぐ盗んでしまっちゃうんです
だからバレなきゃ盗み盗んでもいいということになってるでしょ
世の中あれ あれはマナの働きなんですね
親が子供を育てる時はもうやっぱりこれもう警察に捕まったらよくないとか
学校にバレたらよくないとかね
みんなに悪く思われますよと
だからタバコを吸うなと
と言うんだから で 頭の中で
じゃあみんなに悪く言わなきゃいいでしょうと
みんなにバレなきゃいいでしょという理屈が入っちゃうんです
それで我々作っている社会はどうでしょうかというと
例えば銀行にはテラーマシンというものがありますね
あれ 日本語で何て言いますか
日本にいるのに日本語言葉忘れちゃう
自動なんとかありますね
機械あるでしょ 現金 お金
引き出しです キャッシュコーナーですか
支払いというか キャッシュコーナーでも便利コーナーでもどっちでもいいんですけど
まあ英語ではテラーマシンなんですね
それ そういう機械があって
そこに監視カメラがなかったらどうなるかというと
あれぶっ壊してお金持って行っちゃうんです
で 銀行の中の人々でも今全部コンピューターでやってるんだから
ちょっと数字だけ打てばもう口座にお金入っちゃいますから
それ厳密に管理しておかないと
あの仕事をする人は自分の口座にもう何 1,000万円でも平気でもう打つだけだから入っちゃいますから
そうしないようにありとあらゆる監視をしておかなくちゃいけない
だから警察がいて 政府がいて
部下が武士 上司がいたり
社長がいたり ああだこうだとか
もうものすごい徹底した管理社会なんですね
なぜ管理があるかというと
管理がなくなっちゃったら
人間はもう全く無茶苦茶な生き方をする
それはなぜかというと
仏教から見ればそれはマナなんですよ
人と比べて道徳を守れと言われているだからなんです
いえ そうじゃなくて 客観的にこれは悪いと知ってるならば
法律はあろうがなかろうが関係なく悪いことをしないようになってしまうんです
だから社会も楽になるんです
だから仏教はこの現代知識に応用するならば
そういう風に応用 いいんだ
例えば子供を育てる時でも
会社で社員たちを育てる時でも
会社の規則だから守れではなくて
そのこういう風にしたらこういう結果になりますから
それは良くないことであって
誰でも不幸になることであります
ですから 幸福になるためにはそういうものはするべきではないんだと
そこで社員が一人でいたっても
自分がじゃあ仕事をしないで寝てみようということにはならないんですね
いわゆる自分で責任を持つようになるんですね
他人に比べないで だからいいことをする時でも
やっぱり人にどう思われても
それ気にしちゃったら
それはマーナであって
人にどう思われ 思われ
どう思われるとかではなくて
自分やっていることが自分の良心に従っているかないかと
ただそれだけ 自分がいいことをしたんだからといって
別に宣伝してもらわなくてもいいんですね
今 まあまあ日本でよくあることなんですけど
例えばこの福祉関係やらボランティア活動やら
まあそれよく報告宣伝してくれなきゃ出してくれない
で そこでいつでも新聞で
まあちょっとちっぽけなことをやってでっかい記事を書いたりとか
こういうこういうこと
こういう貢献をしましたとか宣伝したりとかね
ああいうのはまあボランティアでも福祉でも何でもないんです
例えば自分が人を助けてあげたならば
それはいいことだから
それはそれで十分なんです
あの人を認めてくれなかったとか
ちゃんと感謝しなかったとか
いちいち追って追って考えちゃうんですね
それで後で腹が立ったりする
ですから いわゆるいつでも自分の心の充実感
自分の心から見れば 自分の良心から見れば自分が正しいかないか
ただそれだけで十分ですね
マーナない心で そういうふうな世の中の道徳やら教えやら変わるならば
もっと違う社会が現れるはずなんですけど
でも人間ですね 比べる
測ってみる だからもういくら社会進歩したっても苦労だけで法律はどんどん徐々にややこしくなるだけ
息苦しくなるだけの世界
ですから その世界でどんな心理学が発展したって意味がない
ですから このコンプレックスとかね
何とかとかそんなことを勉強したって全然役に立たないと
あの人何々コンプレックスですよと
コンプレックスっていうのはマーナですね
だから仏教の心理学というのはかなり次元違うと
見方が違うというふうなことを理解しておけば
と 疲れました で あの このテーマはこれで終わりますけど
それで欲の心が生まれるといろんなあります
例えばマーナをする場合は欲がない
欲がないという欲の で
欲の心でやってるんですね
コンプレックスの心も欲の心なんです
だからその時その時心は変わりますから
全部我々は欲 貪瞋痴という 8つに分けているんです
ですから簡単なんです
この世の中でどれぐらい欲があっても
どんな種類の欲があっても
どんな種類のコンプレックスあっても
それを勉強しようと思ったらキリがない
その代わりに我々修行から修行から見ると簡単に心を捕まった方がいいんです
ですから それは貪瞋痴やと
すぐそれを捕まってみる
自分 あ これは何々コンプレックスだと
ユングとかなんとか何とか人がこういう風に言ったんだから
そういう風にヴィパッサナー瞑想やっちゃうと
もうもう瞑想にも何もならないんですね
ただ自分の心は欲の心ですから
それだけで見てもらえば正しいし
十分であるし なんでこんな夢見たんだろうとかね
何の意味がありますと
ありましたとかね で そういう夢のことを最近僕に聞いた人もいますけど
なかなか強烈なことを言わない状態
条件の中で言われたんですね
もうこういうこういう夢は
こういうこういう人が見たんですけど
本人も大変喜んで そういう夢見たことについて
で そういうのはどういうことでしょうかと聞くんですけど
まあそういうふうにまあ本人も喜んで言うんだから
なかなかあんまり言えなくなったんだけどね
僕は悪く悪く答えも言わないで
まあいいですね まあそんないい夢見れるということは
それだけで終わったんだけどね
まあどうせ悪い夢見るよりはいい夢見るのはいいことだから
でもその私が最近言われたその夢の類いたってのは
やっぱりそれは本人がすごく見て喜んでるんだから
それはやっぱり欲に欲の心が生まれただけのことで
そういう風に 8つに分けてみますと
じゃあどうしますか？4時半までね
まあ 5分ぐらい休み取りますか
[背景音]